Good morning everyone,
thank you for.
Thank you all for joining us.
This is mit success one nine one,
and we'd like to welcome to welcome you
to this course on introduction to deep
learning.
So in this course you'll learn how to
build remarkable algorithms,
intelligent algorithms,
capable of solving very complex
problems.
They just a decade ago,
we're not even a feasible to solve and
let's just start with this notion of
intelligence.
So at a very high level,
intelligence is the ability to process
information so that it can be used to
inform future predictions and decisions.
Now when this intelligence is not
engineered,
but rather a biological inspiration such
as in humans,
uh,
it's called human intelligence,
but when it's engineered,
we referred to it as artificial
intelligence.
So this course is a course on deep
learning,
which is just a subset of artificial
intelligence.
And really it's just a subset of machine
learning which involves more traditional
methods where we tried to learn a
representations directly from data.
And we'll talk about this more in detail
later today.
But let me first just start by talking
about some of the amazing successes that
deep learning has had in the past.
So in 2012,
this competition called image net came
out which tasks ai researchers to build
an AI system capable of recognizing
images,
objects in images,
and there is millions of examples in
this data set and the winter in 2012 for
the first time ever was a deep learning
based system and when it came out,
it absolutely shattered all other
competitors and crushed the competition.
I'm crushed,
crushed the challenge,
and today these deep learning based
systems have actually surpassed human
level accuracy on the image net
challenge and can actually recognize
images even better than humans can.
Now,
in this class,
you'll actually learn how to build
complex vision systems,
building a computer that knows how to
see,
and just tomorrow you'll learn how to
build an algorithm that will take as
input x ray images and as output,
it will detect if that person has a
pneumothorax.
Just from that single input image.
You'll even make the network explained
to you why it decided to diagnose the
way a diagnosed by looking inside the
network and understanding exactly why it
made that decision.
Deep neural networks can also be used to
model sequences where your data points
are not just single images,
but rather temporarily dependent.
So for this you can think of things like
predicting the stock price,
translating sentences from English to or
even generating new music.
So actually today you'll learn how to
create and actually you'll create
yourselves and algorithm that learns
that first listened to hours of music,
learns the underlying representation of
the notes that are being played in those
songs and then alerts to build brand new
songs that have never been heard before.
And there are really so many other
incredible success stories of deep
learning that I could talk for many
hours about it and we'll try to cover as
many of these as possible as part of
this course.
But I just wanted to give you an
overview of some of the amazing ones
that we'll be covering as part of the
labs that you'll be implementing.
And that's really a goal of what we want
you to accomplish as part of this class.
Firstly,
we want to provide you with the
foundation to do deep learning to
understand what these algorithms are
doing underneath the hood,
how they work,
and why they work.
We will provide you with some of the
practical skills to implement these
algorithms and deploy them on your own
machines and we'll talk to you about
some of the state state of art and
cutting edge research that's happening
in a deep learning industries,
deep learning academia institutions.
Finally,
the main purpose of this course is we
want to build a community here at mit
that is devoted to advancing the state
of artificial intelligence.
Advancing a state of deep learning.
As part of this course will cover some
of the limitations of these algorithms.
There are many.
We need to be mindful of these
limitations.
So I said we as a community can move
forward and create more intelligent
systems.
But before we do that,
let's just start with some
administrative details in this course.
So this course is a one week course.
Today is the first lecture we meet
everyday this week,
10:30
AM to 1:30
PM,
and this during this three hour time
slot,
we're broken down into a one and a half
hour time slots,
around 50 percent of the course.
Each and each of those half a half
sections of this course will consist of
lectures,
which is what you're in right now,
and the second part is the labs where
you will actually get practice
implementing what you learn in lectures.
We have an amazing set of lectures lined
up for you,
so today we're going to be talking about
some of the introduction to neural
networks,
which is really the backbone of deep
learning.
We're also talking about modeling
sequence data,
so this is what I was mentioning about
the temporarily dependent data.
Tomorrow we'll talk about computer
vision and deep generative models.
We have one of the inventors of
generative adversarial networks coming
to give that lecture for us,
so that's going to be a great lecture
and the day after that we'll touch on
deep reinforcement learning and some of
the open challenges in ai and how we can
move forward past this course.
We'll spend final two days of this
course talking or hearing from some of
the leading industry representatives
doing deep learning in their respective
companies and these are bound to be
extremely interesting,
extremely exciting,
so I highly recommend attending of these
as well.
For those of you who are taking this
course for credit,
you have two options to fulfill your
greatest assignment.
The first option is a project proposal.
It's a one minute project pitch that
will take place during Friday and for
this you have to work in groups of three
or four and what you'll be tasked to do
is just come up with a interesting deep
learning idea and tried to show some
sort of results if possible.
We understand that one week is extremely
short to create any type of results or
even come up with an interesting idea
for that matter,
but um,
we're going to be giving out some
amazing prizes,
so including some Nvidia,
Gpu and Google homes,
uh,
on Friday you'll,
like I said,
give a one minute pitch.
There is somewhat of an arts to a
pitching your idea and just one minute,
even though it's extremely short,
so we will be holding you to a strict
deadline up that one minute.
The second option is a little more
boring,
but you'll be able to write a one page
paper about any deep learning paper that
you find interesting.
And really that's if you can't do the
project proposal,
you can do that.
This class has a lot of online resources
you can find support on Piazza.
Please post if you have any questions
about the lectures to labs,
installing any of the software,
et Cetera.
Also,
try to keep up to date with the course
website where we'll be posting all of
the lectures,
labs and video recordings online as
well.
We have an amazing team that you can
reach out to at any time in case you
have any problems with anything,
feel free to reach out to any of us and
we want to give a huge thanks to all of
our sponsors who without this,
without their support,
this class would simply not happened the
way,
uh,
the way it's happening this year.
So now let's start with the fun stuff
and let's start by actually asking
ourselves the question,
why do we even care about deep learning?
So why now and why do we,
why do we even sit in this class today?
So traditional machine learning
algorithms typically defined sets of
preprogrammed features and the data and
they work to extract these features as
part of their pipeline.
Now,
the key differentiating point of deep
learning is that it recognizes that in
many practical situations,
these features can be extremely brittle.
So at deep learning tries to do is learn
these features directly from data as
opposed to being hand engineered by the
human.
That is,
can we learn if we want to learn to
detect faces,
can we first learn automatically from
data that to detect faces,
we first need to detect edges and the
image compose these edges together to
detect eyes and ears,
then compose these eyes and ears
together to form higher level facial
structure and this way,
deep learning represents a form of a
hierarchical model capable of
representing different levels of
abstraction in the data.
So actually the fundamental building
blocks of deep learning,
which are neural networks have actually
been existing,
have actually existed for decades.
So why are we studying this now?
Well,
there's three key points here.
The first is that data has become
much more pervasive.
We're living in a big data environment.
These algorithms are hungry for more and
more data and accessing that data has
become easier than ever before.
Second,
these algorithms are massively parallel,
likable,
and can benefit tremendously from modern
gpu architectures that simply just did
not exist just less than more than a
decade ago.
And finally,
due to open source tool boxes like
tensorflow,
building and deploying these algorithms
has become so streamlined,
so simple that we can teach it in a one
week course like this,
and it's become extremely deployable for
the massive public.
So let's start with now looking at the
fundamental building block of deep
learning.
And that's the perceptron.
This is really just a single neuron in a
neural network.
So yeah,
I do have a perceptron or a single
neuron is extremely simple.
Let's start by talking about the forward
propagation of information.
Through this data unit,
we defined a set of inputs x one x m on
the left,
and all we do is we multiply each of
these inputs by their corresponding wait
theta one through,
say the end,
which are those arrows.
We take this weighted,
we will take this weighted combination
of all of our inputs,
sum them up and pass them through a
nonlinear activation function.
And that produces our output.
Why?
It's that simple.
So we have m inputs,
one output number,
and you can see a summarized on the
righthand side as a mathematics single
mathematical equation.
But actually I left out one important
detail that makes the previous slide not
exactly correct,
so I left that this notion of a bias
biases,
uh,
that green term you see on the left,
and this just represents some way that
we can allow our model to learn or we
can allow our activation function to
shift to the left or right.
So it allows,
if we provide,
it allows us to,
um,
when we have no input features to still
provide a positive output.
So on this equation,
on the right,
we can actually rewrite this using
linear Algebra and dod products to make
this a lot cleaner.
So let's do that.
Let's say x capital x is a vector
containing all of our inputs.
X One,
three,
Xn capitol theater is now just a vector
containing all of our status.
They don't want to say to him,
we can rewrite that equation that we had
before is just applying a dot product
between x and data.
Adding our bias fate is zero.
And applying our nonlinear u,
G,
g.
Now you might be wondering,
since I've mentioned this a couple times
now,
what is this nonlinear function g?
Well,
I said it's the activation function,
but,
uh,
let's see an example of what in practice
ge actually could be.
So one very popular activation function
is the sigmoid function.
You can see a plot of it here on the
bottom right,
and this is a function that takes its
input.
Any real number on the x axis and
transforms it into an output between
zero and one,
because I'll,
I'll put to this function are between
zero and one.
It makes it a very popular choice in
deep learning to represent
probabilities.
In fact,
there are many types of nonlinear
activation functions in deep neural
networks.
And here's some of the common ones
throughout this presentation.
You'll also see tensor flow code
snippets like the ones you see on the
bottom here,
since we'll be using tensorflow for our
labs.
And well this is some way that I can
provide to you to kind of link the
material in our lectures with what
you'll be implementing in labs.
So the sigmoid activation function,
which I talked about in the previous
slide,
now on the left,
is a.
it's just a function,
like I said,
it's commonly used to produce
probability outputs.
Each of these activation functions has
their own advantages and disadvantages.
Underwrite a very common activation
function is rectified linear unit or
value.
This function is very popular because
it's extremely simple to compute.
It's piecewise linear.
It's zero before with inputs less than
zero,
it's x with any input greater than zero,
and the gradients are zero or one with a
single nonlinearity at the origin.
And you might be wondering why we even
need activation functions.
Why can't we just take our dod product
at our bias and that's our output.
Why do we need the activation function?
Activation functions introduce
nonlinearities into the network.
That's the whole point of why
activations themselves are nonlinear.
We want to model nonlinear data in the
world because the world is extremely
nonlinear.
Let's suppose I gave you this,
this plot green and red points,
and I asked you to draw a single line,
not a curve.
Just align between the green and red
points to separate them perfectly.
You would find this really difficult and
probably you could get as best as
something like this.
Now,
if your activation function and your
deep neural network was linear century,
just composing linear functions with
linear functions,
your output will always be linear,
so the most complicated deep neural
network,
no matter how big or how deep,
if the activation function is linear,
your output can only look like this,
but once we introduced nonlinearities,
our network is extremely more.
As the capacity of our network has
extremely increased,
we're now able to model much more
complex functions.
We're able to draw decision boundaries
that were not possible with only linear
activation functions.
Let's understand this with a very simple
example.
Imagine I gave you a train network like
the one we saw before.
Sorry,
I trained perceptron not in network yet.
Just a single node and the weights are
on the top,
right,
so status zero is one and the state of
vector is three and negative to the
network has two inputs,
x one and x two,
and if we want to get the output,
all we have to do is apply the same
story as before.
So we apply the product of x and Theta,
we add the bias and apply or
nonlinearity,
but let's take a look at what's actually
inside.
Before we apply that nonlinearity,
this little,
it looks a lot like just a two d line
because we have two inputs and it is.
We can actually plot this line way
equals zero in feature space.
So this is space where I'm plotting x
one,
one of our features on the x axis and x
to the other feature.
On the y axis,
we plot that line.
It's just a decision boundary separating
our entire space into two sub spaces.
Now,
if I give you a new point,
negative one,
two,
and plotted on the sub and this feature
space,
depending on which side of the line of
false on,
I can automatically determine whether
our output is less than zero or greater
than zero.
Since our line represents a decision
boundary equal to zero,
now we can follow the mass on the bottom
and see that computing the inside of
this activation function.
We get one minus three minus two,
sorry minus four,
and we get minus six at the output
before we applied the activation
function.
Once we apply the activation function,
we get zero point zero,
$0 to so it negative what was applied to
the activation functionalists negative
because we fell on the negative piece of
this sub space.
Well,
if we remember with the sigmoid function
actually defines our space into two
parts greater than one point five and
less than point five.
Since we're modeling probabilities and
everything is between zero and one.
So actually our decision boundary where
the input to our network equals zero.
Sorry,
the.
Sorry.
The input to our activation function
equals zero,
corresponds to the output of our
activation function being greater than
or less than point five.
So now that we have an idea of what a
perceptron is,
let's just start out by understanding
how we can compose these perceptrons
together to actually build neural
networks.
And let's see how this all comes
together.
So let's revisit our previous diagram up
the perceptron know if there's a few
things that you learned from this class,
let this be one of them and we'll keep
repeating it over and over.
In deep learning,
you do a dot product,
you apply a bias and you add your non
linearity.
You keep repeating that many,
many times for each node,
each neuron in your neural network,
and that's a neural network.
So let's simplify this diagram a little.
I removed the bias since we are going to
always have that and we just take her
for granted from Nolan,
I'll remove all of the weight labels for
simplicity and note that z is just the
input to our activation function.
So that's just the dot product plus our
bias.
If we want the output of the network,
why we simply take z and we apply or
nonlinearity like before we wanted to
find a multi output perceptron.
It's very simple.
We just added another perceptron.
Now we have two outputs.
Y One and y two.
Each one has weight matrices,
has weight factor theta corresponding to
the weight of each of the inputs.
Now let's suppose we want to go the next
step deeper.
We want to create now a single layer
neural network.
Single layered neural networks are
actually not deep networks yet.
They're only.
They're still shallow networks.
There are only one layer deep,
but let's look at the single layer
neural network where now all we do is we
have one hidden layer between our inputs
and outputs.
We call this hidden layer because it's
states are not directly observable.
They're not directly forced by by the AI
designer.
We only enforce the inputs and outputs.
Typically the states in the middle are
hidden and since we now have a
transformation to go from our intimate
space to our hidden hidden layer space
and from our hidden layer space to our
output layer space,
we actually need to weight matrices,
data,
one end data to corresponding to the
weight matrices of each layer.
Now,
if we look at just a single unit in that
hidden layer,
it's the exact same story as before.
It's one perceptron.
We take it stopped product with all of
the exits that came before it.
And we apply A.
Sorry,
we take the dot product of the exes that
came before with the weight matrices.
Fate,
is that a one?
In this case,
we apply a bias to get [inaudible].
And if we were to look at a different
hidden unit,
let's say z three,
instead we would just take different
weight matrices,
different,
uh,
our dod product would change,
our bias would change,
but it does,
I see change,
which means it's activation would also
be different.
So from now on,
I'm going to use this symbol to denote
what is called as a fully connected
layer.
And that's what we've been talking about
so far,
so that's every note in one layer is
connected to every node and another
layer by these weight matrices.
And this is really just for simplicity,
so I don't have to keep redrawing those
lines.
Now,
if we want to create a deep neural
network,
all we do is keep stalking these layers
and fully connected weights between the
layers.
It's that simple.
But the underlying building block is
that single perceptron said single dod
product nonlinearity and bias.
That's it.
So this is really incredible because
something so simple at the foundation is
able to create such incredible
algorithms.
And now let's see an example of how we
can actually apply neural networks to a
very important question that I know you
are all extremely worried about.
You care a lot about.
Here's the question you want to build an
ai system that answers the following
question.
Will I pass this class?
Yes or no?
One or zero is the output to do this.
Let's start by defining a simple to
feature model.
One feature is the number of lectures
that you attend.
Second feature is the number of hours
that you spend on your final project.
Let's plot this data.
In our feature space.
We apply greenpoint's of people who
pass.
Red Points are people that fail.
We want to know,
given a new person,
this guy,
he spent a day,
spent five hours on their final project
and went to four lectures.
We want to know did that person pass or
fail the class and we want to build a
neural network that will determine this.
So let's do it.
We have two inputs.
One is for the others.
Five,
we have one hidden layer with three
units and we want to see the final
output probability of passing this
class,
and we computed as zero point one or 10
percent.
That's really bad news because actually
this person did pass the class.
They passed it with probability one.
Nope.
Can anyone tell me why the neural
network got this?
Such so wrong?
Why did it do this?
Yeah,
it is.
Exactly.
So this network has never been trained.
It's never seen any data.
It's basically a baby.
It's never learned anything.
So we can't expect it to solve a problem
and knows nothing about.
So to do this,
to tackle this problem with training a
neural network,
we have to first define a couple things.
So first we'll talk about the loss.
The loss of a network basically tells
our algorithm or our model how wrong our
predictions are from the ground truth.
So you can think of this as a between
our predicted output and our actual
output.
If the two are very close,
if we predict something that is very
close to the true output,
our loss is very low.
If we predict something that is very far
in a high level sense,
far like in distance,
then our loss is very high and we want
to minimize this from happening as much
as possible.
Now,
let's assume we were not given just one
data point one student,
but we're given a whole class of
students.
So as previous data,
I use this entire class from last year
and if we want to quantify what's called
the empirical loss,
now we care about how the model did on
average over the entire Dataset.
Not for just a single student,
but across the entire data set and how
we do that is very simple.
We just take the average of the loss of
each data point.
If we have end students,
it's the average over end data points.
This has other names besides empirical
last.
Sometimes people call it the objective
function,
the cost function,
et cetera.
All of these terms are completely the
same thing.
Now,
if we look at the problem with binary
classification,
predicting if you pass or fail this
class,
yes or no,
one or zero,
we can actually use something that's
called the softmax cross entropy loss.
Now,
for those of you who aren't familiar
with cross entropy or entropy,
this is an extremely powerful notion
that was actually developed,
were first introduced here at mit over
50 years ago by Claude Shannon.
Uh,
in his master's thesis.
Like I said,
this was 50 years ago.
It's huge in the field of signal
processing thermodynamics.
Really all of our computer science had
seen in information theory.
Now,
instead of predicting a single one or
zero output,
yes or no,
let's suppose we want to predict a,
um,
continuous valued function,
not will I pass this class,
but what's the grade that I will get it
as a percentage,
let's say zero to 100 now we're no
longer limited to zero to one,
but can actually output any real number
on the number line.
Now instead of using cross entropy,
we might want to use a different loss.
And for this,
let's think of something like a mean
squared error loss where as your
predicted and you're true output
diverged from each other,
the loss increases as a quadratic
function.
Okay,
great.
So now let's put this new loss
information to the test and actually
learn how we can train a neural network
like quantifying it's lost.
And really if we go back to what the
loss is at the very high level,
the last tells us how the network is
performing,
right?
Did last tells us the accuracy of the
network on a set of examples.
And what we want to do is basically
minimize the loss over our entire
training set.
Really,
we want to find the set of parameters
data such that that loss jff data,
that's our empirical loss is minimum.
So remember jff data takes us data and
data's just our weights.
So these are the things that actually
define our network.
Remember that the last is just a
function of these weights.
If we want to think about the process of
training,
we can imagine this landscape.
So if we only have two weights,
we can plot this nice diagram like this,
Beta zero and Beta one or two weights
there on the floor.
They're on the planer.
Access on the bottom,
JFK to zero,
and three to one are plotted on the the
Z axis.
What we want to do is basically find the
minimum of this loss of this landscape.
If we can find the minimum,
then this tells us where our loss is,
the smallest,
and this tells us where theater,
where or what values of Beta zero and
Beta one we can use to attain that
minimum loss.
So how do we do this?
Well,
we start with a random guests.
We'd pick a point say to zero state of
one,
and we start there,
we compute the gradients of this point
on the last landscape.
That's Dj de Seto.
It's how the loss is changing with
respect to each of the weights.
Now this gradient tells us the direction
of highest ascent,
not decent.
So this is telling us the direction
going towards the top of the mountain.
So let's take a small step in the
opposite direction.
So we negate our gradient and we adjust
our weight.
So should we step into the opposite
direction of that gradient such that we
move continuously towards the lowest
point in this landscape until we finally
converged at a local minima.
And then we just stop.
So let's summarize this with some pseudo
code.
So we randomly initialized our weights.
We loop until convergence the following.
We compute the gradient at that point,
and when simply we apply this update
rule with the update takes as input the
negative gradient.
Now let's look at this term here.
This is the gradient.
Like I said,
it explains how the loss changes with
respect to each weight and the network,
but I never actually told you how to
compute this and this is actually a big,
a big issue in neural networks.
I've just kind of took it for granted.
So now let's talk about this process of
actually computing this gradient because
without that gradient you're kind of
helpless.
You have no idea which way down is,
you don't know where to go and your
landscape.
So let's consider a very simple neural
network,
probably the simplest neural network in
the world.
It contains one hidden units,
one hidden layer and one output unit.
And we want to compute the gradient of
our loss j of data with respect to theta
to just stay at a two for now.
So this tells us how a small change in
theater to will impact our final loss at
the output.
So let's write this out as a derivative.
We can start by just applying a chain
rule because jff data is dependent on
why,
right?
So first we want to back propagate
through why our output all the way back
to theater.
To we can do this because why are
output,
why is only dependent on the input and
data too.
That's it,
so we're able to just from that
perceptron equation that we wrote on the
previous slide,
computer closed form,
great end or close from derivative of
that function.
Now let's suppose I change state of two
to three to one and I want to compute
the same thing,
but now for the previous layer and the
previous wait,
all we need to do is is a supply chain
role.
One more time back propagate those
gradients that we previously computed
one layer further.
It's the same story.
Again,
we can do this for the same reason.
This is because Z,
one are hidden state is only dependent
on our previous and put x and that
single weight Fado one.
Now the process of backpropagation is
basically you repeat this process over
and over again for every weight in your
network until you compute that gradient
Dj d theater,
and you can use that as part of your
optimization process to find your local
minimum.
Now,
in theory,
that sounds pretty simple.
I hope.
I mean,
we just talked about some basic chain
rules,
but let's actually touch on some
insights on training these networks and
computing backpropagation and practice.
Now,
the picture I showed you before,
it's not really accurate for modern deep
neural network architectures.
Modern deep neural network architectures
are extremely non convex.
This is an illustration or a
visualization of the landscape like I've
planted before,
but have a real deep neural network of
resonate 50 to be precise.
This was actually taken from a paper
published about a month ago,
was the author's attempt to visualize
the last landscape,
to show how difficult gradient descent
can actually be.
So if there's a possibility that you can
get lost in any one of these local
Minima,
there's no guarantee that you will
actually find a true global minimum.
So let's recall that update equation
that will we defined during gradient
descent.
So take a look at this term here.
This is the learning rate.
I didn't talk too much about it,
but this basically determines how large
of a step we take in the direction of
our gradient and in practice setting
this learning great.
It's just a number,
but setting it can be very difficult if
we set the learning rate too low than
the model get may get stuck in a local
minima and may never actually find its
way out of that local Minima ps at the
bottom of local man.
Well obviously gradient is zero,
so it was just going to stop moving.
If I said the learning rate too large,
it could overshoot and actually
diverged.
Our model could blow up.
Okay.
Ideally we want to use learning rates
that are large enough to avoid local
minima,
but also still converged to our global
minimum so they can overshoot just
enough to avoid some local minima but
then converge to our global minimum.
Now,
how can we actually set the learning
rate?
Well,
one idea is let's just try a lot of
different things and see what works
best,
but I don't really like the solution.
Let's try and see if we can be a little
smarter than that.
How about we tried to build an adaptive
algorithm that changes its learning rate
as training happens.
So this is a learning rate that actually
adapts to the landscape that it's in.
So the learning grade is no longer a
fixed number.
It can change,
it can go up and down,
and this will change depending on the
location that the,
that the update is currently yet the
great end in that location,
maybe how fast we're learning and many
other many other possible situations.
In fact,
this process of optimization in deep
neural networks and non convex situation
has been extremely explored.
There's many,
many,
many algorithms for computing adaptive
learning rates and here are some
examples that we encourage you to try
out during your labs to see what works
best and for your problems,
especially with real world problems.
Things can change a lot depending on
what you learn in lecture and what
really works in lab and we encourage you
to just experiment,
get some intuition about each of these
learning rates and really understand
them at a higher level.
So I want to continue this talk and
really talk about more the practice of
deep neural networks.
This incredibly powerful notion of many
batching and I'll focus for now if we go
back to this gradient descent algorithm,
this is the same one that we saw before
and let's look at this term again so we
found out how to compute this term using
backpropagation,
but actually what I didn't tell you is
that the computation here is extremely
calm,
is extremely expensive.
We have a lot of data points potentially
in our data set and this takes us input
a summation over all of those data
points.
So if our Dataset is millions of
examples large,
which is not that large in the realm of
today's deep neural networks,
but this can be extremely expensive just
for one iteration,
so we can compute this on every
iteration.
Instead,
lets create a variant of this algorithm
called stochastic gradient descent where
we compute the gradient just using a
single training example.
Now this is nice because it's really
easy to compute the gradient for a
single training example.
It's not nearly as intense as over the
entire training set,
but as the name might suggest,
this is a more stochastic estimate,
as much more noisy.
It can make us jump around the landscape
in ways that we didn't anticipate.
It doesn't actually represent the true
gradient of our data set because it's
only a single point,
so what's the middle ground?
How about we define a mini batch of be
data points,
compute the average gradient across
those data points,
and actually use that as an estimate of
our true gradient.
Now this is much faster than computing
the estimate over the entire batch
because b is usually something like 10
to 100 and it's much more accurate than
sgd because we're not taking a single
example,
but we're learning over a smaller batch.
A larger batch.
Sorry.
Nope.
The more accurate our gradient
estimation is,
that means the more or the easier it
will be for us to converge to the
solution,
faster means will converge smoother
because we'll actually follow the true
landscape that exists.
It also means that we can increase our
learning great to trust each update
more.
This also allows for massively parallel
likable computation.
If we split up batches on different
workers on different gps or different
threads,
we can achieve even higher speed ups
because each thread can handle its own
batch.
Then they can come back together and
aggregate together to basically create
that single learning grade or complete
complete that single training iteration.
Now finally,
the last topic I want to talk about is
that of overfitting and regularization.
Really this is a problem of
generalization,
which is one of the most fundamental
problems and all of artificial
intelligence,
not just deep learning,
but all of artificial intelligence,
and for those who aren't familiar,
let me just go over on a high level what
overfitting is,
what it means to generalize.
Ideally in machine learning,
we want the model that accurately
describes our test data,
not our training data,
but our test data
said differently.
We want to build models that can learn
representations from our training data
and still generalized well on unseen
test data.
Assuming you want to build a line to
describe these points under fitting
describes the process on the left,
where at the complexity of our model is
simply not high enough to capture the
nuances of our data.
If we go over 50 on the right,
we're actually having too complex of a
model and actually just memorizing our
training data,
which means that if we introduced a new
test data point,
it's not going to generalize well.
Ideally what we want to,
something in the middle,
which is not too complex to memorize all
of the training data,
but still a contains the capacity to
learn some of these nuances in the test
set.
So just to address this problem,
let's talk about this technique called
regularization.
Now regularization is just this way that
you can discourage your models from
becoming too complex and after we've
seen,
as we've seen before,
this is extremely critical because we
don't want our data.
We don't want our models to just
memorize data and only do well in our
training set.
One of the most popular techniques for
regularization in neural networks is
dropout.
This is extremely simple idea.
Let's revisit this picture of a deep
neural network and then drop out all we
do during a training on every iteration,
we randomly drop some proportion of the
hidden neurons with some probability p,
so let's suppose p equals point five.
That means we dropped 50 percent of
those neurons like that.
Those activations becomes zero and
effectively they're no longer part of
our network.
This forces the network to not rely on
any single node,
but actually find alternative paths
through the network and not put too much
weight on any single example with any
syngrid single nodes,
so it discourages memorization.
Essentially,
John,
every iteration,
we randomly drop another 50 percent of
the nodes,
so in this iteration I may drop these on
the next iteration.
I may drop those and since it's
different on every iteration,
you're encouraging the network to find
these different paths to his answer.
The second technique for regularization
that we'll talk about is this notion of
early stopping.
Now we know that the definition of
overfitting actually is just when our
model starts to perform worse and worse
on our test data set.
So let's use that to our advantage.
To create this early stopping algorithm,
if we set aside some of our training
data and use it only as test data,
we don't train with that data.
We can use it to basically monitor the
progress of our model on unseen data so
we can plot this curve.
We're on the x axis,
we have the training iterations.
On the y axis,
we have to loss.
Now they start off going down together.
This is great because it means that
we're learning or training,
right?
That's great.
There comes a point though where the
testing data,
where the testing data set and the loss
for that Dataset starts to plateau.
Now,
if we look a little further,
the training data set loss will always
continue to go down as long as our model
has the capacity to learn and memorize
some of that data,
but that doesn't mean that it's actually
generalizing well because we can see
that the testing dataset has actually
started to increase.
This pattern continues for the rest of
training,
but I want to focus on this point here.
This is the point where you need to stop
training because after this point,
you are overfitting and your model is no
longer performing well on unseen data.
If you stopped before that point,
you're under fitting and you're not
utilizing the full potential to full
capacity of your network.
So I'll conclude this lecture by
summarizing three key points that we've
covered so far.
First,
we've learned about the fundamental
building blocks of neural networks
called the perceptron.
We've learned about stacking these
units,
these perceptrons together to compose
very complex hierarchical models,
and we've learned how to mathematically
optimize these models using a process
called backpropagation and gradient
descent.
Finally,
we addressed some of the practical
challenges of training these models in
real life that you'll find useful for
the labs today,
such as using adaptive learning rates,
batching and regularization to combat
overfitting.
Thank you.
And,
uh,
I'd be happy to answer any questions
now.
Otherwise,
we'll have rainy talk to us about some
of the deep sequence models for modeling
temporal data.